das ist amalia ulmer 26 jahre wohnhaft
in los angeles
hier ihr profil auf facebook und
instagram hübsch zart glücklich verliebt
so dokumentiert sie ein sorgen loses
unbeschwertes leben und lässt über
75.000 follower daran teilhaben
dann ein erstes drama die trennung von
freund das verändert sie sie bricht aus
produziert entwickelt düstere gedanken
hat sex nimmt drogen
sie ziert sich auf ihren körper lässt
sich größere brüste machen
verliert die kontrolle bis zum
psychischen zusammenbruch
die täuschung ist perfekt was wir eine
echte biografie wirkt entpuppt sich als
performance mit ihrem kunstprojekt traf
sie den nerv der social media zeit und
erntete große aufmerksamkeit
wir kontaktieren die echte amalia
uhrmann
ich habe im vorfeld sehr viel recherche
betrieben
ich wollte herausfinden wie sich die
leute ausdrücken in welcher subkultur
sie sind wie sie schreiben wie sie ihre
gefühle online ausdrücken nicht nur wie
sie sich mit bildern darstellen sondern
auch wie sie dinge benennen welche herr
stark sie brauchen
niemand wusste dass sie diese existenz
nur vortäuschte nicht einmal ihre
freunde sie wechselte dauern zwischen
realität und fiktion führte drei monate
lang ein doppelleben
irgendwann wurde es mir zu viel
ich hatte die schnauze voll sowas
braucht viel zeit es war ja nicht so
dass ich zu dieser zeit nichts anderes
tat ich habe ausstellungen gemacht habe
essays geschrieben und dann sagt es
immer so ein moment ich muss ein bild
machen gehen maria ullmann löste mit
ihrer scheinbar graffy reale gefühle aus
nicht nur anonyme follower glaubten was
sie sahen auch ihr bekanntenkreis hatte
keinen zweifel
alle nahmen anteil in den kommentaren
zeigten mitgefühl besonders als sie die
brust-op miete ich bete dafür dass du
dich gut erholt gratuliere ich bin froh
hast du das getan was du wolltest
ich wollte damit spielen weil ich mich
dafür interessiere und ich weiß dass die
menschen darauf sehr stark reagieren die
leute mögen es vorher nachher bilder
anzuschauen
die künstlerin fasziniert die rollen und
stereotypen der selbstdarstellung
das fassaden leben reizt sie sie
bezeichnet den körper als reisekoffer
unseres bewusstseins
so hatte sie denn auch keinerlei skrupel
bei ihrer enttäuschung projekt
ich glaube alles ist performance alles
sogar dass sich selber sein ist
performance weil das gar nicht existiert
du bist immer so wie du gerne gesehen
werden möchtest das unverfälschte ich
gibt es nicht man ist immer von äußeren
einflüssen bestimmt identität als reiner
reflex irgendwie beunruhigend